it's Odell Beckham jr. this is the LJ
Hopkins I'm Adam p.m. I'm Erin Donnell
I'm Cooper Cup I'm Russell Wilson
quarterback - Seattle Seahawks and we're
playing start [ __ ] but I'm gonna be
giving a category
I'm have to pick one to start one to
bench and one to cook thora mansion code
let's get it
oh man that's football movies I'm gonna
go to start I'm gonna Remember the
Titans from my favorite movies of all
time I'm gonna go to bench
I'm gonna go Rudy I'm gonna go I'm gonna
cut I'm gonna go Friday night life I
will start fried my likes that's high
school football
that's this something that's very big in
the state of Texas and you got to put
boobie miles in the game baby
start Remember the Titans bench Friday
Night Lights and cut Rudy Titan start
benching I'm cutting Rudy sorry I've got
a lot of respect for you tea but I just
doesn't like those first two of my first
two favors so I gotta go with this start
with the wings
I always got how it wins gotta make sure
you gotta have your favorite dip which
orange the ranch sauce he's who I would
bench cuz PC you always have said letter
deal I'm gonna cut
I'm not eating those seven layer dip
just give me some queso some chips and
I'm good to go
start pieces we couldn't wings and we
[ __ ] say up seven layer dip I love
something letter dip seven layers I'm
going to start seven layer dip because
that's not lost I'm gonna bench winners
and then I'm gonna cut pizza wings I'm
starting love wings a big win guys and
then I'm and then I'm a bench
pizza
and then I don't think I've ever had
seven-layer do honest it sounds tasty
for sure starting pizza
especially with Italian sausage it's
tough to go against Tom right he's
really the goat but I can't start him
over tiger so it's like I got to give
him like equal playing time or something
we won't cut Serena or bencher and we'll
share the playing time between Tom Brady
and Tiger Woods all right Tom Brady you
know champion football it's a hard sport
win my best arena
I'm gonna cut Tiger I'll start on aisle
three I'm not getting anybody you can't
kind of go it's hard it's really I don't
know I don't even know start the quarter
three [ __ ] the blueprint I'm a cook
give it to that time why is my favorite
rapper I'm going to bench $0.50 don't
keep him on the team get rich or die
trying and I'm not for me I agree with
that
that's exactly what I want to do and
just dumb chance that he had it just had
a whole club rocket if you want to have
the whole club rocket I'll talk about
warmups I'm talking about pregame I'll
talk about the anywhere just see inside
a dorm room or anything
start the blueprint base the get ready
to die trying to cut the car to three
the Carter thing was good but you go
listen to the Carter to get is like a
man go to track two on the car to two
right now you can't say anything about
it
you starting all three all three of
those classic albums I'm DeAndre Hopkins
I'm Odell Beckham jr. I'm Russell Wilson
and that was start bench cut